bench bureau is the editor-in-chief of
The Daily wire syndicated columnist and
the host of the wildly successful ben
shapiro show it's podcast hey Ben let's
start by talking a little bit about what
happened down in Florida last week with
parkland that high school there this
time the debate seems different and it
seems like people in Washington on both
sides of the aisle are trying to make
sure that school violence you know they
can do something about it they haven't
been able to get a handle on it so far
what's your suggestion I mean I think
the first thing that has to be done is
obviously security these schools needs
to be radically escalated when I was in
high school I went to a Jewish day
school out in Los Angeles and a mass
shooter named Buford furo actually drove
past our school and saw there was armed
security outside he wanted targeted
Jewish Center and he proceeded to drive
right past it he saw that he didn't want
to go where there was armed security he
went over to the JCC instead in the East
Valley here and shot up the JCC armed
security does make a difference and
having lots of security guards at these
schools would be a welcome thing I think
students should have their IDs check
from they walk onto campus we should be
guarding our children like we got our
banks I mean these are our most valuable
asset and the idea that anybody would
oppose this on any ground seems to be
unreasonable right I just worry about
you know in situations when there's a
budget and teachers got to buy their own
supplies then you gotta go tell these
people who are living off property taxes
go spend money for secured armed
security I wish there was a way to do
that nationwide yeah I mean I think that
there should be talk about you know
federal dollars going toward things like
that and I think that if what if there
are states that are spending on on
various you know boondoggles around the
country it seems to me there should be
priority number one that's gonna be
definitely near the top of the list it
should not be near the bottom then we
interviewed a guy Sheriff Richard Jones
he's the sheriff in Butler County which
is an Ohio pretty pretty tough guy we
liked and we all liked him he put on
Twitter he wrote to the teachers in that
area said come I'll teach you concealing
can give you concealed carry license our
teacher training you how to carry a gun
so that you can take them inside your
classrooms and I'll do this for free
hundreds of teachers have responded
listen to this when people say teachers
don't want to be armed in school that's
not true this is a community in Ohio
we're between Cincinnati and day
and it's overwhelming with the numbers
we're gonna do it for free we're going
to teach the teachers we're gonna give
them a concealed carry permit when
they're done in Ohio you can carry a
concealed carry in the schools if the
school board allows you to do that we're
gonna do the Train we're starting the
training next week we're gonna have
fifty to a class and we're leading by
example I guess the idea is if someone
if the shooter were to walk into a
classroom you just don't know who in the
school is carrying a gun yeah and I
think that would be the great solution I
mean you're trusting your safety to the
teachers anyway every single day y'all
send your kids to school and we're
telling these teachers that it's better
for them to jump in front of doors and
block bullets with their body than to
arm these same teachers so that they can
actually defend the students that it
makes zero sense I mean some of the
heroes that we saw at Parkland including
the coach there who died in order to
protect students would have been better
if that coach had been able to protect
himself and protect the students with a
gun on campus again
you're already trusting these teachers
with the safety of the kids then what
you're taking the background checks that
allowed Nicholas Cruz to legally get a
gun are you okay with that knowing his
years of mental illness that they've
been dealing with in the school system
not obviously this is insanity I mean
the fact that the background check
system is is not transparent the fact
that you'll have federal background
checks that are not coordinated with
local background checks as we've seen in
other mass shooting cases the fact that
the FBI was twice told about this guy
and that twice they did nothing about it
one of the big problems would be push
for gun legislation is that there
actually has to be someone who enforces
the legislation there in tens of
thousands of people across the country
or straw buyers who are illegally
purchasing guns to hand off to people
who cannot legally purchase guns and
something like forty four of them were
prosecuted in a several year period so
if the government is going to be given
additional power they should at least be
using the power they have right now to
prevent people who are bad from getting
them yeah it's more dangerous to buy
beer for kids than it is a gun for a kid
right now enforce the laws we have